[Music]
to better understand where the story of
halo infinite begins let's have a brief
recap of where we're at with the
reclaimer saga
during the events of halo 4 the ancient
forerunner known as the didact has
returned
[Music]
having been locked up in stasis for
thousands of years he still blames
humanity for the wars of the past
master chief is able to defeat didact
and his army of prometheans
but loses cortana in the process as she
uses the last of her power to protect
the chief from the detonation of a
nuclear bomb
[Music]
in halo 5 master chief discovers that
cortana is still alive
she used 4runner technology to survive
and expand across the galaxy
with her rejuvenation she intends to
bring peace to the universe
and believed that it was up to the
created ais to protect it
cortana calls on all ai throughout the
galaxy to assist in her goal
as well as reactivating ancient
forerunner weapons called guardians
she plans on using them to forcibly
bring peace to the planets
regardless of whether the occupants want
it or not
to cortana and the created this may seem
like the most logical approach
but for sentient races this essentially
means the removal of free will
master chief goes rogue in an attempt to
save her and talk her into standing down
while the unsc concerned that master
chief is being manipulated by the ai
sends an escort of spartans to bring him
back
halo 5 ends with cortana humming to
herself while appearing to activate one
of the halo rings
the halo infinite campaign begins near
the damaged halo installation known as
sita halo
after a stranded unsc soldier known as
the pilot
saves master chief from being sucked out
into space the pilot goes on to tell the
chief of a recent unsc defeat
with heavy damage to the ring world it
would appear that the unsc were engaged
in a conflict between the banished
returning as an enemy faction from halo
wars 2 and potentially the created
on top of this mask chief has also
discovered the weapon a cortana-like ai
who claims that the original cortana was
deleted after infiltrating sita halo
however the chief city hadn't deleted
her but also there was a built-in
subroutine that was designed to delete
the weapon once cortana was gone adding
a further amount of ambiguity to the
situation
at this stage it appears that the story
of halo infinite will be centered around
taking down the banished forces on zeta
halo and uncovering the mystery around
cortana and the weapon
it's likely that the unsc plus various
others will be looking to destroy
cortana
but as in halo 5 master chief will be
attempting to stop her without going to
those extremes
if possible
given the number of races affected by
cortana's plans it's also possible that
the master chief will be fighting more
than just a couple of different factions
this time
there is the potential for quite a
number of different groups making their
way to zeta to put a stop to the ai who
has threatened to take control of the
galaxy
there has been quite a bit of concern
around the open world concept that was
announced people fear that it will
become a ubisoft or even a destiny clone
in the way that they manage it
but from what i've been able to check
out it's far from this
in fact i would goes far to say that
this feels much more like a classic halo
campaign than we've seen in many many
years
just on a much much larger scale
i felt the same sort of vibes that i had
with the original game all those years
ago
the game starts with master chief crash
landing on zeta halo
it has been months since the unsc forces
lost the conflict that took place
and the banished now control the
majority of the ring planet
the chief's job is to secure and bring
the unsc soldiers who are spread across
the map together and recapture ground
for humanity
there were forward operating bases
across the land that are now under
banished control
capturing these will provide resources
like weapons and equipment but also the
ability to fast travel and summon
vehicles
while there is still a clear mission
direction marker there are a number of
smaller conflicts and objectives around
the map
these are outside of the main missions
but will often have a named enemy within
that needs to be taken out
these enemies will not only have some
background law but specialized weaponry
that can be collected
it's up to the player as to whether they
would like to push through the missions
or explore the entire map rescuing
soldiers capturing forward operating
bases and taking down named enemies
some missions certainly feel more linear
with tighter bases and funnel points but
even in this situation everything just
feels much larger and more epic
speaking of which remember in the
original game when you'd come across
unsc soldiers and they would tag along
and help out
this would usually only be for short
bursts as the mission structure would
usually cut them off
but this isn't the case in infinite
there is a seemingly limitless supply of
soldiers dotted around that constantly
respawn especially around the captured
forward operating bases
i'm kind of keen to see how many i can
bring together at once and watch how
they handle a large conflict
love him or hate him halo will be
following the battle pass trend of other
shooters in the market
they have stated that this isn't working
as intended right now and while we've
seen a few adjustments to this recently
i have a feeling we'll be seeing a few
more in the coming weeks
each battle pass season will last for
three months with week-long events
dotted throughout
the seasons are how you unlock new gear
and customization options
fortunately if you miss a season or
didn't manage to complete it you have
the option to go back and work on past
tracks
halo infinite will not launch with a
co-op campaign or forge mode
rather than delay the game again they've
decided to bring these out when they're
ready to be released
we shouldn't expect to see the co-op
until at least may 2022
and forge another three months after
that
but as always the divs have warned that
these dates are only goals
these could potentially shift again if
other priorities come up
most people will be aware of this but i
have to chuck it in there halo infinite
multiplayer is free to play in cross
platform with cross progression across
xbox one xbox series x and pc
the halo open world will also be getting
a day night cycle obviously not one of
the most major of additions but it's the
little things that count
for the immersion of the world this is a
good step to take and will help it feel
a bit more alive
and last but certainly not least this
will be the last standalone halo title
for at least the next 10 years
343 industries has no plans to make any
other standalone halo titles in the
future instead infinite will act as a
platform to further halo experiences
chrisley explains
halo infinite is the start of our
platform for the future
we want infinite to grow over time
versus going into those numbered titles
and having all that segmentation that we
had before
it's really about creating halo infinite
as the start of the next 10 years for
halo and then building that as we go
with our fans and the community
i hadn't originally planned to dive into
halo infinite but i've been having a
hell of a lot of fun with the
multiplayer up until now
plus the other games i covered just
really haven't got a lot going on at the
moment i actually really didn't want to
try this halo as i didn't actually enjoy
some of the more recent games it was
affecting some of the good memories i
had from the early days of the franchise
but i'm so glad i did because this is
looking to be shaping up into something
special
so while i'll still be covering the
other games with the infinite campaign
coming out on the 8th of december i
already know i'm going to be putting in
some serious hours
so expect to see more videos coming out
in the future
anyway i hope you're looking forward to
it as much as i am catch in the next one
cheers
you